tout de suite notre second débat des bas
de société avec cette question faut-il
inscrire le droit à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse dans la
Constitution avant dans les battre un
premier constat toutes les Françaises
n'ont pas le même accès au centre IVG la
faute au désert médicaux reportage à
Issoudun et Vierzon dans le centre Val
de Loire avec Fabien avec air
[Musique]
de proximité bonjour d'accord donc vous
souhaitez faire une interruption de
grossesse je vais vous demander la date
de vos dernières règles s'il vous plaît
un avortement par voie médicamenteuse
jusqu'à la septième semaine de grossesse
à l'hôpital d'Issoudun dans l'Indre les
sages-femmes du Centre périnatal en
pratique une quarantaine par an la
première échographie ce sera pour dater
précisément la grossesse
et puis ensuite vous aurez un autre
rendez-vous pour faire le dossier on
vous expliquera tout le déroulé le délai
de prise en charge est de 3 jours en
moyenne mais au-delà de la septième
semaine de grossesse les choses se
compliquent l'IVG chirurgicale
obligatoire passé ce délai est
impossible à Issoudun ou le bloc
opératoire a fermé au début des années
2000 dans le département de l'Indre seul
l'hôpital de Châteauroux pratique cette
intervention et il faut souvent attendre
pour obtenir un rendez-vous nous avons
des délais souvent qui sont un peu longs
parce qu'il y a un manque d'opérateur
parce qu'il y a un manque de créneau
disponible opératoire et de ce fait nous
adressons souvent des personnes dans
d'autres centres qui sont pas partis du
département mais qui sont voisins afin
que la prise en charge soit plus rapide
puisque les femmes en règle générale
sont dans une situation souvent
inconfortable psychologiquement et c'est
difficile pour elle d'attendre plus
longtemps carlindre est frappé par la
désertification médicale ici les
urgences de nuit viennent d'ailleurs de
fermer par manque de personnel face aux
difficultés pour recourir à un
avortement chirurgical une loi votée en
début d'année pourraient apporter une
solution elle vise à permettre au
sage-femmes de pratiquer les IVG
chirurgicales
Océane sur Saint sage-femme à l'hôpital
de Vierzon dans le département voisin du
Cher a décidé de se faire former ce qui
m'a réellement motivé c'est que on est
quand même deux sur un territoire où il
y a peu de médecins qui pratiquent l'IVG
instrumental ou l'IVG même
médicamenteuse tout court on sait à me
sembler important que les sages-femmes
puissent prendre le relais et qu'on soit
plusieurs à être formés pour pouvoir se
remplacer et permettre une offre de
soins
accessible à toutes les femmes de notre
de notre territoire mais en attendant le
décret d'application de la loi les
sages-femmes ne sont pas encore
autorisés à pratiquer cette opération le
directeur de l'hôpital espère que ce
sera bientôt le cas son établissement
est candidat pour expérimenter cette
nouvelle démarche sur le territoire
organiser l'accès à l'IVG est une
obligation légale s'inscrire dans les
canons de la loi est une obligation donc
la question de se poser même pas par
contre avoir une équipe motivée prête à
se former et accompagner
à accompagner ce projet
tout à fait essentiel parce que on est
aussi dans un bassin de population qui
le nécessite car pour les femmes en
centre Val de Loire l'accès à
l'avortement reste plus compliqué
qu'ailleurs et la médecine de ville ne
vient pas combler les carences de
l'hôpital
un rapport parlementaire de 2020 pointé
le manque de gynécologue et de médecins
généralistes pratiquant l'IVG dans la
région
je vous présente tout de suite les
invités de notre débat Muriel Jourda
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes sénatrice LR
du Morbihan et secrétaire de la
commission des lois Floriane volts
bonsoir bienvenue porte-parole de la
Fondation des femmes Anne bézina bon
soirée bienvenue dans
conférences en droit public et Laetitia
cruppa éditorialiste politique un
chiffre pour commencer on va on va
parler de ces déserts médicaux une femme
sur trois recours à une IVG au cours de
sa vie mais Muriel jourdat on le voit
les Français elles sont pas égales face
aux droits à l'avortement c'est un vrai
problème qui je pense ne relève pas de
la loi mais tout simplement des
difficultés de notre système de santé
alors on l'entendait à l'instant de
votre sujet on manque de gynécologue on
manque de gynécologue en ville mais on
en manque aussi à l'hôpital et le fait
de pouvoir former des sages-femmes
peut-être un début de solution car on
sait qu'un gynécologue de se forme pas
en trois jours donc c'est vrai qu'il y a
une inégalité d'accès aux soins qui
n'est pas légale le droit et le même
pour tous mais qui est de fait lié à
l'état de notre système de santé alors
là-dessus je vous propose un témoignage
celui de de Clarisse elle est infirmière
et c'était lors d'une manifestation
justement de défense du droit à
l'avortement et écoutez bien
[Musique]
je vous avoue que je n'ai pas le chiffre
en tête mais c'est une dénonciation
c'est une demande des associations comme
le planning familial c'est un acte qui
n'est pas valorisé financièrement et qui
il y a pas d'incitation en tout cas pour
les médecins à le pratiquer et par
ailleurs c'est vrai qu'il y a aussi pour
l'avortement un une clause de conscience
qui explique aussi que les
professionnels le peuvent refuser de le
médecin qui peuvent refuser de le
pratiquer mais est-ce que ça peut
provoquer la fermeture d'un centre IVG
est-ce que c'est est-ce que c'est déjà
ça à votre connaissance alors pas
forcément j'ai pas cette expertise mais
non le las fermeture des centres IVG
c'est le résultat de choix de politique
publique d'accord alors on va parler
maintenant évidemment dans ce débat
c'est le cœur de notre débat de de cette
proposition de loi votée par les députés
la semaine dernière prévoyant d'inscrire
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
dans la Constitution de la Cinquième
République unchaine busina comment ça a
été reçu ça par les constitutionnalistes
de manière assez mitigé parce qu'en
réalité un constitutionnaliste il aime
la constitution et la manière de faire
de la Constitution à la française et
c'est vrai que dans notre tradition on
n'a pas trop l'habitude de toucher à la
Constitution pour y ajouter des droits
qu'on pourrait qualifier le
générationnel de société qui font plutôt
l'objet des lois on a toujours eu
beaucoup de confiance en la loi en
France et donc notre Constitution ou la
réserve plutôt à des cas plus rares à
des mécanismes institutionnels
procédureaux surtout notre Constitution
de la Cinquième République qui est
vraiment un catalogue institutionnel
mais qui ne contient quasiment pas dans
son texte même de droit fondamentaux
alors les droits fondamentaux dans notre
Constitution en réalité ils sont plutôt
situés dans le préambule mais qui
lui-même est très court qui à peine un
alinéa qui renvoie lui-même à des textes
de notre histoire alors c'est c'est tout
le charme français c'est notre passé
historique que nous avons eu envie de
valoriser mais c'est tous paradoxe
puisque par exemple dans plusieurs des
propositions de loi qui avait été faites
depuis le mois de juin on proposait
d'ajouter ce droit à lentement dans le
préambule de notre Constitution
historique de 46 mais ça revenait à
quelque chose d'un peu anachronique
c'est-à-dire de toucher un texte
historique pour y ajouter quelque chose
actuelle donc ce qui devenait un peu
incohérent mais pourtant tous nos droits
fondamentaux nous nous les avons dans
des catalogues historiques donc c'est
assez original et puis sa manifeste
aussi en France la confiance que nous
faisons dans le juge constitutionnel
pour les consacrer au cas par cas en
fonction de la conciliation des droits
et c'est vrai qu'on a pas du tout le
même système que les États-Unis
les États-Unis à un moment de se débat
il y a eu beaucoup de réactions après le
vote de l'assemblée des échanges parfois
musclés on va dire comme le 20 octobre
dernier on est au Sénat je suis pas sûr
de la date mais c'est pas grave entre le
garde des séries du pont Moretti et le
sénateur reconquête Stéphane Ravier on
écoute les sujets graves ne manquent pas
en France mais nous voilà en train de
perdre un temps précieux en discutant
d'une problématique importée des
États-Unis sans aucun rapport avec la
réalité de notre pays et c'est pourtant
ce dont les auteurs de ce texte se
réclament dans l'exposé des motifs vous
êtes hors sujet je dirais même qu'il n'y
a pas de sujet vous nous donnez une
formidable raison
de voter ce texte imaginons qu'un jour
vous soyez au pouvoir ce que Dieu te
plaise
moi je pense que l'avortement est
sérieusement menacé dans ce pays vous
voyez ah ouais
ouais
bon et puis je vais vous dire une chose
là quand on parle de droits de l'homme
et surtout de droit de la femme on n'est
jamais hors sujet monsieur le sénateur
alors c'était bien le 20 octobre mais
c'était lors de l'examen au Sénat avant
l'assemblée voilà voilà la précision on
va en discuter avec Quentin calmer tout
de suite puisque Quentin l'adoption de
de cette proposition de loi la semaine
dernière ça signifie pas la fin du
processus législatif ouais très précise
sur ce qui peut se passer maintenant on
a vu beaucoup de messages la semaine
dernière lorsque effectivement le texte
a été voté à l'Assemblée nationale on a
pu croire que c'était déjà la fin du
parcours législatif regardez ce tweet de
Mathilde pano victoire la proposition de
loi que je porte est adoptée par une
large majorité même chose chez Caroline
Fiat une autre députée LFI c'est fait
cette historique l'Assemblée nationale
vient d'adopter la proposition de loi de
Mathilde de panot inscrivant l'IVG dans
notre Constitution en lisant ces
messages on peut donc penser que le
simple vote de ce texte la semaine
dernière a suffi à faire rentrer l'IVG
dans la Constitution sauf que c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué alors il faut
déjà que les deux chambres adoptent le
même texte exactement la France dispose
de deux chambres c'est un système
bicaméral l'Assemblée nationale et le
Sénat l'idée est de compliquer la tâche
à tout changement de Constitution tant
le texte fondateur de la sécurité doit
être protégé pour les problèmes donc le
Sénat a déjà examiné une telle
proposition de loi c'était le 19 octobre
dernier c'était dans la niche dans
l'espace réservé des écologistes et
voyez le score le vote s'est joué à
quelques dizaines de voix mais une
majorité a rejeté le texte écouter le
lendemain la réaction de la sénatrice
communiste Laurence Cohen
partout y compris en France le droit à
l'IVG est remis en cause et la façon de
le protéger et bien c'est effectivement
de l'inscrire dans la Constitution et je
me réjouis quand même du cheminement de
cette idée parce que le Parti communiste
est porteur de cette idée depuis 2012 on
a fait une proposition de loi en 2017 et
aujourd'hui et bien finalement ça a pu
être discuté au niveau du Sénat grâce à
la niche de d'Europe Écologie Les Verts
et on voit que le vote a été quand même
assez juste donc ça veut dire que les
idées progressent et que on va y arriver
même si le senavote le même texte que
l'assemblée Quentin il reste une étape
et non des moindres un référendum et oui
lorsque c'est un parlementaire qui est
un initiative il faut que le projet de
loi de réforme constitutionnel soit
validé par une majorité dans chacune des
deux chambres puis soumis à un vote des
Français d'où le fait que beaucoup de
parlementaires de gauche favorables à la
mesure sur l'IVG dans la Constitution
souhaiterais que ce soit le gouvernement
à la veine à la manœuvre pourquoi parce
que dans ces cas là le processus est
différent le gouvernement écrit un
projet de loi constitutionnel en
cherchant un accord entre les deux
chambres à son national et Sénat elles
sont ensuite réunies en congrès pour
modifier la Constitution il faut alors
réunir les 3/5 de ce congrès vraiment
maintenant plus générale Emmanuel Macron
veut une telle réforme constitutionnelle
avec beaucoup de choses dedans depuis
2017 mais il a dû reculer après la faire
Benalla donc il a depuis annoncé pendant
la campagne avoir lancé un comité pour
réfléchir à une telle nouvelle réforme
constitutionnelle on le voit on comprend
mieux pourquoi le dossier est un peu
dans une impasse politique merci
beaucoup quand un Muriel jourdat vous
êtes je crois opposé à cette inscription
du du droit à l'avortement dans la
Constitution expliquez-nous pourquoi
pourquoi alors je vais essayer d'être
synthétique d'abord parce
qu'effectivement ça a été indiqué tout à
l'heure c'est un sujet qui me semble ne
pas toucher la société française en
réalité on n'a pas eu si je ne me trompe
pas moins de six propositions de loi
pour constitutionnaliser cette liberté
des femmes de recourir à
cette pléthore est de PPL est justifiée
par un événement qui est on le sait une
décision de la Cour suprême aux
États-Unis qui a pour le dire
sommairement car je ne suis pas
spécialiste de droit constitutionnels
aux États-Unis qui a tranché sur le fait
que c'était aux États fédérés de
légiférer sur le principe même de l'IVG
qui protégeait le droit à l'avortement
au niveau fédéral il y a eu un retour un
retour de jurisprudence un renversement
de jurisprudence tout ça se passe aux
États-Unis nous sommes assez différents
des Etats-Unis nous n'avons pas ce
système d'État fédéral et surtout nous
n'avons pas le même débat sociétal sur
l'IVG je lisais récemment les mythermes
ont eu lieu que c'était un sujet c'est
un sujet entre les républicains entre
les démocrates d'ailleurs c'est un peu
le sujet aussi de nomination des juges à
la Cour suprême aux États-Unis qui va
l'emporter et si les républicains
l'emportent sur les démocrates et bien
évidemment ça peut entraîner ce type de
réaction c'est pas un sujet en France
pour pas un sujet politique alors
j'entendais ma collègue Laurence Cohen
qui disait qu'il y a des remises en
question mais j'aimerais bien savoir de
qui par qui à quel moment de quelle
façon parce que nous venons quand même
de vivre deux élections majeures la
présidentielle et les législatives je
n'ai entendu nulle part quelqu'un faire
de l'IVG un cheval de bataille ou un
moyen de se différencier des autres des
autres acteurs politiques à ces moments
forts de la vie politique je pense qu'il
enfin l'IVG qui a fait l'objet quand
même de cette modifications depuis 1975
toujours pour mieux permettre d'exercer
ce droit ce qu'on appelle le droit à
l'avortement n'est pas en cause en
France et n'est pas en risque en France
Floriane Volt vous n'êtes pas de cet
avis pourquoi selon vous le est-ce que
déjà je vais poser une question plus
générale est-ce que le droit à l'IVG est
menacé en France pour répondre à madame
la sénatrice oui évidemment que enfin je
ne partage pas les vie de Madame la
cinétrices sans surprise l'IVG ça fait
plusieurs années la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG ça fait
plusieurs années que les associations
demande c'est enfin demande cette mesure
américaine
elle a agi comme un révélateur plus que
comme une provocateur c'est à dire que
vraiment ça aussi mis en lumière et les
États-Unis on le sait ne sont pas un
pays isolé par leur puissance ils font
tâche d'huile et tout sujet de politique
américaine fait tâche d'huile sur sur le
monde nous l'IVG on voit il est menacé à
notre sens il est menacé dans le monde
on voit les décisions récentes en gris
en Pologne en Italie aux États-Unis il y
a un mouvement général de contestation
de l'IVG pourquoi parce que quand on
parle divergent on parle du corps des
femmes on parle de droit des femmes il y
a des mouvements
réactionnaires conservateurs qui
financent des mobilisations politiques
contre l'avortement et donc est-ce que
pardon de vous interrompre est-ce que la
décision américaine
redonne de l'énergie à ceux qui qui
éventuellement pourrait s'attaquer à
exactement la décision américaine c'est
une victoire sans précédent pour ces
mouvements religieux anti IVG il y a un
rapport du Parlement européen qui est
sorti il y a deux ans qui montre que les
mouvements conservateurs américains mais
également les les familles russes
financent à hauteur de 86 milliards on
finit à hauteur de 86 milliards en 10
ans les mouvements anti IVG en Europe et
à l'égard de plus 120 millions il me
semble en France donc vraiment il y a
des mobilisations politiques 120
millions c'est immense quand on le
compare au budget des associations
féministes qui elles portent ce combat
oui je voulais rebondir ce que vous
disiez madame la sénatrice parce que
c'est vrai que l'argument que vous
apportez sur ce plateau ce soir on
l'entend il est répété alors je ne sais
pas si c'est un anément de langage mais
c'est important du débat qui qui
viendrait des États-Unis et le fait que
aucun parti ne remettrait en cause le
droit à l'IVG mais j'aimerais vous poser
cette question quel problème cela
postule si ce droit est inscrit dans la
Constitution quel est le problème c'est
un problème qui pourrait peut-être être
plus soulevé par Madame que moi
c'est-à-dire nous sommes législateurs
notre idée tout de même mais de ne pas
faire n'importe quoi avec le droit moi
j'écoute une de dire le droit ce n'est
jamais qu'un outil pour nous mais nous
disposons quand même une boîte à outils
assez fournie en France et il faudrait
la garder un peu en ordre jusqu'à la
Constitution pour moi la Constitution ne
sert pas à ça la Constitution en France
organise les pouvoirs publics elle
définit également un certain nombre de
droits fondamentaux mais pas dans le
corps de la Constitution elle-même
évidemment or il s'agit d'un droit qui
découle des droits fondamentaux enfin le
Conseil constitutionnel a déjà eu
l'occasion de trancher ce problème de
dire que effectivement la liberté de
recours à l'IVG elle découvre la liberté
des femmes qui elle-même découle de
l'article 2 de la Déclaration des Droits
de l'Homme et du Citoyen donc si on
commence à entrer dans la Constitution
tous les droits qui sont
constitutionnels et qui découlent le
principe conduit dans la Constitution
mais on va refaire un code civil enfin
ça n'a pas grand sens il y a aussi une
certaine rigueur juridique à avoir dans
le vote dans votre argument c'est
uniquement la rigueur juridique non mon
argument et qu'il n'y a pas de danger en
France sur l'avortement car j'entends
j'entends ce qui est dit par Madame Volt
mais je n'en écoutez le seul la seule
crainte que j'ai entendu c'est le
rassemblement national que va faire le
rassemblement national s'il arrive au
pouvoir mais on le sait il a voté la
semaine dernière le rassemblement
national et il y a plus de députés
rassemblement national qui ont voté pour
la constitutionnalisation de l'IVG que
de députés qui ont voté contre donc
arrêtons de nous faire peur avec des
choses qui n'existent
suffisamment de temps pour ça
anne-charley de Blizzard et évidemment
effectivement est-ce que la Constitution
peut servir à ça ou doit servir à ça
alors il y a plusieurs niveaux de
réponse à apporter parce que la
Constitution elle-même ne ne dit pas
grand chose on peut malheureusement en
tant qu'interprète lui faire dire
beaucoup
d'être la plus impartiale possible la
question centrale c'est est-ce que la
Constitution sert à ça clairement à
l'heure actuelle la constitution de
notre cinquième République que nous
avons non est une constitution on l'a
déjà dit purement procédura le
distribution des compétences qui ne
signifie pas du tout que la France n'est
pas une patrie des droits fondamentaux
bien au contraire notre juge
constitutionnel en reconnaît très
souvent même encore récemment avec le
patrimoine commun de l'humanité pour la
protection de l'environnement mais
on a en effet cette tradition à ne pas
avoir tendance à inscrire les droits
sociétaux dans la Constitution on l'a
déjà dîné au moins le mouvement de
constitutionnalisation qu'est-ce qu'il
apporte à une société et ça il faut
revenir bien avant dans notre histoire
et c'est vrai que les déclarations de
droits auparavant on avait l'habitude
d'en mettre une à chaque au fond de fils
de chaque constitution et bien les
déclarations de droits avaient apporté
au peuple le soin de choisir qu'est-ce
qui dans leur société dans l'état qu'ils
voulaient ils entendaient qu'est-ce
qu'ils entendaient faire de fondamental
qu'est-ce qu'ils entendaient placé
au-dessus de tous les changements de
majorité et je crois aujourd'hui qu'on
ne peut pas être complètement sourd à ce
mouvement de constitutionnalisation qui
certes va sûrement changer un petit peu
l'objet de la Constitution on ne peut
pas dire par exemple cette proposition
de loi n'introduise pas une forme
d'incohérence puisqu'elle est dans
l'article 66 relative à l'autorité
judiciaire donc on a évidemment quelque
chose qui constitutionnellement n'est
pas très rigoureux en terme juridique
mais l'aspiration populaire c'est
laquelle c'est d'interdire que les
changements de majorité puisse remettre
en cause ce droit trop facilement et ça
c'est quand même la vocation principale
de la constitutionnalisation si je vous
entends c'est quoi c'est tenir compte
d'un mouvement sociétal profond c'est ça
pour la protection du du corps des
femmes le droit des femmes enfin c'est
un peu cette idée là aussi la logique
consistera à l'inscrire donc dans la
Constitution exactement c'est un peu ce
qu'on avait voulu faire en jurisprudence
dans les années 80 ce qui n'est
absolument pas fonctionné l'effet
cliquet c'est-à-dire qu'on se disait en
matière de droit fondamentaux et bien
dès lors qu'on en consacre un nouveau on
essaiera de dire qu'on ne peut pas
revenir en arrière on a considéré que ça
liait trop législateur et donc on est
revenu sur cette jurisprudence mais
c'est un peu ça il faut essayer d'avoir
avec la constitutionnalisation c'est
quel que soit les majorités en place le
peuple français va considérer que tel
droit doit être considéré comme acté
dans le marbre constitutionnel et c'est
un symbole donc la Constitution ici
j'aurais plus son rôle de symbole qui
évidemment le rôle d'objet juridique
particulièrement utile dans ces moments
vous êtes également dans ce dans ce
mouvement porté par
l'opinion en si l'on en croit ce dernier
sondage d'ailleurs publié ce mardi son
agifop 86% des Françaises et des
Français favorables à l'inscription du
droit à l'avortement dans la dans la
Constitution ça vous conforte forcément
c'est une tendance à la hausse en plus
oui c'est vraiment depuis deux trois ans
on l'avait aussi fait un sondage avec la
Fondation des femmes on avait 91% des
Français et des françaises qui étaient
favorables donc il y a vraiment une un
attachement très fort des Français des
françaises avec ce à ce droit et nous
notre démarche c'est vraiment ce que ce
que vous disiez c'est aussi se dire
c'est pas lorsque la maison brûle
comprend une assurance et
le mettre dans la Constitution c'est
aussi rendre plus difficile
la suppression de ce droit et on voit
que ce droit est subi de part et d'autre
des attaques dès lors que des parties
plus conservateurs des parties qui sont
hostiles au droit des femmes arrivent au
pouvoir c'est ce qui vient d'arriver en
Italie cette démarche elle existe
pourquoi parce que l'IVG bien sûr que
c'est pas le même marqueur que en effet
que les États-Unis ou c'est devenu
vraiment un sujet très fort de
de différence entre entre les
républicains et les démocrates néanmoins
c'est un marqueur du droit des femmes et
c'est aussi pour nous vraiment
enthousiasmant et un signe très fort et
de progrès de faire rentrer ce droit qui
est la base de la liberté des femmes
aujourd'hui si on n'a pas le droit de
maîtriser sa maternité si on n'est pas
en mesure d'accéder à l'IVG
on n'a pas la liberté on n'est pas égal
aux hommes on a plus cette liberté on
n'est plus dans l'égalité et pour nous
c'est aussi faire rentrer dans la
Constitution ça et ça concerne 51% des
citoyens est-ce que le combat je suis
plutôt favorable à l'idée d'une
constitutionnalisation même si c'est pas
à moi de donner mon avis mais est-ce que
l'urgence c'est pas plutôt le premier
thème dont on a parlé dans ce débat
c'est-à-dire le l'accès quoi le fait que
aujourd'hui il y a pas d'accès à
l'avortement alors que alors que c'est
c'est un droit pour toutes les femmes en
France quoi alors pour mettre ce sont
pas de débats qui s'excluent l'un
l'autre je pense qu'on peut vraiment
agir et il faut d'ailleurs agir sur ces
deux sujets bien sûr que une fois qu'on
aura la l'IVG dans la Constitution si il
y a plus aucun centre IVG en France et
c'est ce qui est en train de se passer
aux États-Unis en moins de deux mois il
y a 13 États qui ont adopté des
législations anti-vg donc vraiment ça va
donc oui de moi suivant la décision donc
je pense qu'il faut avancer sur les deux
tableaux et l'un n'est pas ne doit pas
empêcher d'avancer sur l'autre sondage
qu'est-ce qui vous inspire il m'inspire
que probablement personne n'a répondu à
la question qui était posée comme tous
les sondages qui ont des questions
techniques je suis navré de le dire mais
je ne crois vraiment de valeur à son je
lui donne une valeur je lui donne une
valeur technique en réalité la question
de la constitutionnalisation de l'IVG
c'est avant tout une question juridique
technique je suis sûr qu'il y a
énormément de gens qui ont répondu qui
était pas au courant des étapes donc que
quand même vous a détaillé tout à
l'heure ça pense que la connaissance de
la hiérarchie des normes EN FRANCE enfin
et majoritairement inconnu de de la
plupart de la population en revanche il
démontre l'attachement je pense des
personnes qui répondent à la possibilité
de recourir à l'IVG parce que c'est un
peu je crois la façon dont la question a
été entendue êtes-vous favorable ou pas
à l'IVG et évidemment il y a un
attachement mais enfin qui n'est remis
en cause par personne à vrai dire en
France en tout cas
les
autorités religieuses le remettre en
cause certaines personnalités à
l'extrême droite leur mettent en cause
donc on peut pas dire qu'aujourd'hui il
n'est pas du tout remis en cause ce
n'est pas vrai alors actuellement ce
n'est pas le reste c'est pas par
personne c'est ce que vous voulez je
parlais de personnes qui ont la
possibilité de faire modifier la loi
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de partie
religieux qui fasse modifier la loi et
vous savez il y a certainement beaucoup
plus de personnes que qui dans leur fort
intérieur sont opposés l'avortement y
compris au sein des parlements mais vous
ne verrez personne et depuis la loi de
75 je ne pense pas qu'il y ait jamais eu
une seule proposition de loi qui a eu
pour objet de supprimer l'IVG enfin nous
c'est quoi c'est une sorte de tabou
parlementaire vous êtes en train de nous
dire c'est juste que c'est juste qu'un
parlementaire ne léger pas pour faire
valoir ses propres opinions nous ne
sommes pas des militants de nous-mêmes
nous ne sommes pas des lobbyistes de nos
propres intérêts le parlementaire il est
là pour faire valoir ce qu'il estime et
de l'intérêt général nous n'avons pas
tous la même position sur l'intérêt
général et aujourd'hui je pense qu'il
n'y a pas un parlementaire qui puisse
penser que l'intérêt général serait de
supprimer la liberté des femmes de
recourir à l'IVG tout simplement
une question qui se pose avec cette
constitutionnalisation c'est à dire que
on veut inscrire dans le marbre
constitutionnel on a on a ce souhait de
consacrer pour le futur je crois pas
qu'on puisse dire véritablement que à
l'heure actuelle le droit à l'IVG je
suis je vous partage largement votre
sentiment et menacé politiquement dans
son dans son essence néanmoins je crois
qu'il y a une projection qui se fait sur
un mouvement de régression des droits
qu'on ne peut malheureusement pas nier
et la France d'ailleurs n'est pas à mon
avis forcément au rang des bons élèves
surtout puisqu'on a eu un état d'urgence
pendant près de 7 ans entre l'état
d'urgence attentat et sanitaire donc la
régression des libertés la régression
des droits il faut toujours la craindre
et je crois que justement le mouvement
constitutionnel et le
constitutionnalisme en tant que tel doit
toujours éveiller sur cette tendance
possible malheureusement toujours
difficilement politiquement imaginable
mais dans les périodes de crise de
régression et donc je crois profondément
que la Constitution lorsqu'elle peut
jouer ce rôle de garant au moins permet
d'être sûr que les mouvements les crises
les évolutions sociétales ne permettront
pas d'affecter ce qu'on a inscrit dans
ce marbre constitutionnel donc je crois
je crois qu'il y a il y a quelque chose
à vérifier quand même notamment dans
l'Europe proche sur les mouvements
parfois un peu nationalistes qui vont
ré-ayer des consciences qu'on croyait
parfois enterré depuis des siècles et
qui renessent sous le fleuron de
certains discours un peu populaires un
peu un peu aux atouts populistes qui
peuvent être dangereux pour nos libertés
c'est vrai que nous enfin pour nous on
le voit l'IVG et menacé de trois façons
il est menacé politiquement comme
j'évoquais ce rapport qui montre
vraiment les mêmes financières très
fortes pour des mouvements qui
organisent des mobilisations
tous les ans en janvier à l'anniversaire
de la loi Veil se tient la Marche pour
la vie la Marche pour la vie elle
bénéficie de financement massif c'est
une organisation massive que peu
d'associations féministes auraient les
moyens de déployer et au cœur de la
dernière marche pour la vie qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé il y a eu une réclame
pour un séminaire qui s'est tenu cet été
la Lejean Academy qui avait pour objet
de former les jeunes leaders de la
génération Provis qu'est-ce qui
promettait ce séminaire il s'adressait
aux jeunes de 18 à 25 ans à très faible
coût et il est de les aider à réagir
dans les médias et à se former à la
rhétorique provie donc anti-avortement
donc déjà il y a cette menace politique
qui s'organise
les deux autres mais je voudrais vous
entendre là-dessus est-ce que finalement
vous nous parlez de lobbyiste qui ont
les moyens est-ce que ils sont à
l'oeuvre
au Parlement à l'Assemblée ou au Sénat
alors écoutez pas auprès de moi en tout
cas bon ceci étant je pense qu'on a
aussi le droit
d'avoir une opinion qui ne soit pas
celle d'être systématiquement pro
avortement on a le droit il y a des gens
le droit de penser différemment la
liberté ça n'est pas une idée qui est
imposée par les pouvoirs publics et il y
a des gens qui effectivement ne sont pas
favorables à l'avortement on a parlé des
mouvements religieux mais il y a des
personnes qui ne sont pas nécessairement
religieuses ou en tout cas n'ont pas de
non pas de responsabilité religieuse qui
sont opposées à l'avortement ils ont le
droit de l'être ça n'est pas pour ça que
c'est une menace enfin bien sûr
les femmes de d'y accéder mais pourquoi
ils y sont opposés ils se sont posés
dans aussi une démarche de voilà de
faire reculer ce droit par ton moyen
alors les deux autres raisons justement
attention
la deuxième menace elle est juridique
puisque il y a quelques temps avant la
le vote quelques jours avant le vote de
la loi à l'Assemblée nationale vous
aurez peut-être vu cet organisme qui
s'appelle l'Institut européen pour la
justice pour le droit qui a envoyé à
l'ensemble des députés une lettre leur
disant qu'ils auraient du sang sur les
mains s'il voté pour la proposition de
loi ça c'est du accompagner d'un petit
foetus en plastique cette institut qui
partage je crois la présidence par
l'avocat de Donald Trump agit dans
d'autres pays que la France au niveau de
la Cour européenne des droits de l'homme
donc la Cour européenne des droits de
l'homme qui s'appliquent à nous pour
agir et faire progresser
un lobby à l'oeuvre là
l'information l'accès à l'information
nous à la fondation des femmes on
finance le planning familial pour qu'il
puisse en plus de sa ligne verte
d'écoute pour les femmes qui souhaitent
chercher une information fiable sur
comportement puisse accéder aussi à un
chat en ligne pourquoi parce que c'est
lobby ils sont présents au niveau
européen ils sont présents à la au
Parlement et ils sont aussi présents en
ligne pour désinformer les femmes et les
décourager d'avoir accès à un homme
Laetitia je viens vers vous parce que
vous vous posez la question de savoir si
l'IVG c'est toujours un combat féministe
aujourd'hui oui c'est vrai qu'en que
vous m'avez proposé ce sujet je me suis
posé la question je me suis dit est-ce
que ce sont uniquement les femmes qui
défendent ce droit à l'IVG où les hommes
aussi alors j'aurais tendance à dire que
c'est de moins en moins féministe mais
quand même dans la mise en scène dans la
verbalisation dans les incarnations bref
dans la communication de ce combat ça
reste quand même très féminin plus que
que féministe finalement très féminin et
pour illustrer mon analyse mais vous
proposer une petite séquence qui a eu
lieu justement la semaine dernière aller
à l'Assemblée nationale on va voir les
députés qui sortent à la suite du vote
et on va voir bien sûr Mathilde panneau
qui est celle qui a proposé
dans la Constitution on va écouter ces
femmes qui chantent l'hymne du mouvement
de libération en des femmes regardez et
ensuite on en discute
séparés
[Musique]
mais
je ne sais pas si vous l'avez entendu
mal tu te panneau parce que c'est
vraiment très bref elle dit où est Erwan
Erwan c'est un député MoDem c'est Erwan
Balanant c'est celui qui a permis de
rédiger un amendement qui rassemblait
finalement la proposition renaissance et
la proposition de la nuque pour la
mettre en une et pour pouvoir faire
voter ce texte où et Erwan ben Erwan il
est resté derrière
Erwan n'a pas chanté avec les femmes
c'est peut-être un détail mais pour moi
ça veut dire beaucoup sans faire de jeux
de mots oui vous citez du Michel Berger
mais bon pourquoi pas c'est toujours
très très bien de réécouter dans sa tête
du Michel Berger on va avoir la chanson
pendant toute la soirée merci Laetitia
vous pouvez que les hommes il manque
dans dans ce cas oui je comprends pas
pourquoi on entend essentiellement des
femmes alors que des hommes
œuvrent dans l'ombre pour ce combat je
vous propose de regarder ce qu'a tweeté
Jean-Luc Mélenchon il tue il tweet
lui-même une archive donne ses meetings
de 2012 où déjà il fait cette
proposition regardez
c'est nous qui mettrons pour que plus
personne ne soit tenté d'y toucher quand
les menaces s'accumulent comme nous le
voyons en ce moment c'est nous qui
mettrons dans notre Constitution le
droit à l'avortement qui reconnaît à
chacune le droit de disposer dans le
même son corps d'état la propriétaire
deux personnes c'était il y a 10 ans
alors bien sûr que dans le sillage
ensuite Emmanuel Macron le défend Boris
Vallaud beaucoup de personnalités du
Parti socialiste beaucoup de
personnalités à gauche et puis il y a
aussi
destin qui était quand même le président
qui a permis à la loi veille de voir le
jour mais dans l'expression publique il
est manifeste que ce sont les femmes que
l'on voit que l'on entend or il me
semble que c'est quand même à droite
partagé l'IVG quand on fait un enfant il
y a un homme et une femme jusqu'à
maintenant en tout cas naturellement
biologiquement et plus globalement je
pense que le féminisme je crois ne doit
pas être uniquement féminin justement et
que lorsque on arrivera à ce point
d'équilibre où il ira autant d'hommes
que de femmes qui défendront ce combat
on saura justement vous en parliez tout
à l'heure au point d'équilibre aussi de
l'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
est-ce que c'est un combat féministe
pour vous le droit à l'avancement
ça a été bien justement aujourd'hui
puisque c'était les femmes qui étaient
principalement principalement touchées
mais ce que vous disiez est exact c'est
quand même un président qui était un
homme Valéry Giscard d'Estaing qui l'a
permis avec un gouvernement qui était
piloté par Jacques Chirac donc les
hommes étaient aussi sensibles à ça et
je pense continuent de l'être mais il y
a peut-être je ne sais pas c'est vous
qui pourriez nous le dire une forme de
pudeur est restée en arrière parce que
effectivement une grossesse non désirée
une interruption volontaire de grossesse
ce sont les femmes qui les subissent
physiquement donc je pense que les
hommes pensent peut-être que
ils n'ont pas vocation à être en
première ligne pour un sujet qui nous
concerne physiquement et qui les
concerne aussi puisque vous dites
jusqu'à maintenant un homme évidemment
les enfants mais évidemment que ça
concerne les hommes si on regarde les
votes à l'Assemblée nationale comme au
Sénat vous verrez qu'il y a des hommes
enfin il n'y a aucune partition entre
les hommes et des femmes ça n'est pas
sur ce point-là que la partition s'est
faite dans les votes pour ou contre mais
sur le cette idée de combat féministe
Floriane Volt c'est presque la même
question que est-ce que il faut pas
plutôt
faire en sorte qu'il y ait plus de
centres privilégier vous voyez est-ce
qu'il y a pas des combats féministes
plus importants plus urgent aujourd'hui
en France tous les combats féministes
sont importants
avaient peut-être pas autant de moyens
que d'autres je pense que toutes les
fois où on parle de liberté et de droit
des femmes c'est normal de trouver les
féministes en avant-garde et d'être et
d'être à l'avant de ce combat le combat
pour l'avortement c'est un combat de
l'ensemble des Français et des
Françaises c'est sûr que les
associations féministes sont
particulièrement mobilisées depuis
quelques mois et d'ailleurs c'est aussi
peut-être pour ça on souhaite la
constitutionnalisation parce qu'on a le
sentiment qu'une fois que ce sera dans
la Constitution on pourra aussi faire
autre chose
je vous propose d'entendre tout de suite
l'écrivaine et diplomates françaises
Claudine Monteil elle reprend un peu ce
que vous disiez on va continuer de
parler un peu de du pouvoir de ceux qui
effectivement voudraient éventuellement
revenir sur le droit à l'avortement
écoutez Claudine Monteil je suis très
inquiète pour l'avenir de l'avortement
libre et gratuit dans de nombreux pays y
compris en France y compris en France je
suis très inquiète pour la raison
suivante les lobbys conservateurs contre
l'avortement libre et gratuit sont des
lobbies richissime qui ont des
financements
considérables ces financement augmentent
par an de 5 à 10 fois c'est à dire qu'on
arrive dans plusieurs millions de
dollars de financement insidieux y
compris au sein du Parlement européen
est-ce que
vous avez entendu les arguments de
Florian de vol vous venez d'entendre
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas en train de
sous-estimer finalement le la capacité
de ce lobby à transformer ce qui est une
opinion un mouvement un lobby en action
législative
ecoutez je ne suis pas l'objet des
attentions de ces lobbies donc je j'ai
du mal à estimer quelque chose que je ne
subis pas si ce n'est peut-être mais
c'est à peu près sur tous les textes de
loi un peu sensible de quelle corde
qu'il soit y compris lorsqu'on parle des
animaux on reçoit on reçoit des mails
qui sont tous rédigés de façon identique
enfin très honnêtement je ne pense pas
qu'il y ait un seul parlementaire digne
de ce nom qui soit sensible à des envois
en nombre publicitaires enfin parce que
ça ressemble un peu à ça donc et puis
j'avoue que enfin j'ai tendance à penser
que on ne se laisse pas influencer sur
des choses ou quoi on croit fermement je
peux vous dire que tous les islamistes
de la Terre pourraient m'écrire pour me
dire il faut vous voiler car vous êtes
un être inférieur en tant que femme ce
qui est un vrai combat féministe
aujourd'hui je pense y compris en France
ça ne me pousserait en aucun cas à
mettre un voile enfin soyons
raisonnables nous avons aussi un libre
arbitre et les femmes de ce pays ont
aussi un libre arbitre j'ose espérer
donc
les lobbys peuvent exister très
honnêtement moi je n'en vois pas
beaucoup la couleur pour être un peu
trivial ça n'est pas pour autant qu'ils
vont nous faire changer d'avis enfin
ayant un peu confiance dans le système
législatif dans le bon sens et dans
aussi les convictions que peuvent avoir
certains élus sur des droites que nous
ne voulons pas toucher si un endroit où
on défend le système législatif c'est
ici évidemment
publicités étrangères qui qui protège le
droit à l'IVG dans la Constitution alors
je saurais pas vous donner une recension
exacte mais en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est que des constitutions bien plus
détaillées que la nôtre en matière de
droit fondamentaux existe je pense
notamment à tout ce qu'on a appelé la
mouvance sud-américaine où les
constitutions sont riches de parfois 435
articles où vous avez un détail de luxe
de de droit fondamentaux pour les
animaux pour les autochtones pour les
régions etc et nous en France c'est vrai
qu'on a pas cette tradition de rentrer
autant dans le détail donc sûrement que
d'autres constitutions protège ce genre
de droit que nous on a l'habitude
d'appeler question de société droit
sociétal alors qu'au fond ces questions
de société sont des questions de droit
fondamental comme les autres mais nous
notre habitude française c'est de les
avoir laissé à la garantie du
législateur c'est notre article 34 qui
nous dit ça d'ailleurs la protection
quotidienne des droits fondamentaux
c'est évidemment la loi qui l'assure et
j'ajouterai d'ailleurs que je pense pas
qu'on puisse vraiment opposer la
constitutionnalisation et la liberté et
je vous rejoins largement sur la liberté
d'opinion dans l'un ou dans les deux cas
parce que d'ailleurs les formulations
des premières propositions loi était
tout à fait erronées on entendait parler
de droit alors on va avortement qui
aurait été garantie par la Constitution
or ce droit à l'avortement c'est une
liberté évidemment de la femme elle
n'est jamais obligée d'avoir à avorter
donc un droit à l'avortement ça
donnerait l'impression qu'il y a un
droit à et ça restera de toute façon une
liberté donc la constitutionnalisation
ne changera rien au mouvement des
consciences et malheureusement pas non
plus au pouvoir des lobbies c'est
simplement un acte on l'a déjà dit de
symbolisation que d'autres constitutions
utilisent pour dans mes droits des
animaux les droits de l'environnement
que que nous garantissons Florian Volt
dans le l'extrait qu'on a écouté de la
l'interview de Claudine Monteil elle
parlait de l'Europe vous attendez de là
on peut peut-être terminer là-dessus on
vous attendez de la France qu'elle soit
un peu pionnière en Europe oui mais j'ai
beaucoup d'admiration pour Claudine
Monteil qui était une proche de Simone
de Beauvoir et qui disait elle-même il
suffirait d'une crise aujourd'hui il
suffit de qu'on aille plusieurs crises
et on voit que les droits des femmes
sont menacés on attend beaucoup de
l'Europe c'est vrai que le président
c'était engagé avait souhaité en tout
cas faire modifier la Charte européenne
des deux sauvegardes des droits de
l'homme en ce sens
pour nous c'est évident que l'accès à
l'avortement c'est un droit fondamental
qui doit être garanti dans nos textes
les plus hauts que ce soit la
constitution ou la Convention européenne
de sauvegarde des droits de l'homme il y
a il y a des textes en cours il y a une
action en cours au niveau européen ou
pour l'instant c'est c'est phalogramme
plat alors il me semble que Paul lors de
la présidente française de du parle de
l'Union européenne
précédemment il y a eu un effet des
initiatives qui n'ont pas abouti donc je
crois qu'il y a un discussion je pense
que le Parlement européen n'est pas le
Parlement français et que pour le coup
c'est le hobbies que
donc moi je crois à la puissance son
plus puissants encore en Europe et
notamment il me semble que juste avant
le vote de la semaine dernière la veille
au Parlement européen il y avait ce
fameux institut qui tenait un événement
donc oui il faut c'est aussi un signe
que si la France fait rentrer l'IVG dans
sa constitution c'est aussi un signe
très positif à l'égard de l'ensemble des
pays de l'Union européenne et du monde
mais 10 secondes si je peux me permettre
ça n'est pas à l'Europe de décider sur
ce type de choses ça ne fait pas partie
des compétences que les traités lui
donnent on aura terminé là-dessus de la
précision merci beaucoup merci à toutes
d'avoir participé à ce débat et à
bientôt évidemment sur Public Sénat
votre prochain rendez-vous politique sur
notre antenne le ministre délégué chargé
des relations avec le Parlement franc
qui restèrent qui sera l'invité dans la
matinale c'est à 8 heures du matin belle
soirée à toutes et à tous